Jason hickl is an anthropologist at the
London School of Economics.
Originally from Swaziland.
He spent a number of years living with
migrant workers in South Africa studying
patterns of exploitation and political
resistance in the wake of apartheid.
Alongside is ethnographic work.
He writes about development inequality
and global political economy for the
Guardian and other online outlets.
His new book,
the divide,
a brief guide to global inequality and
it solutions is out now.
Jason,
welcome to under the skin.
Thank you for having me.
Russell.
Is it an honor to have you on?
You're actually a doctor.
I am,
although not the kind of,
it can save your life,
sadly.
Good.
Because you know,
I mean,
we could talk about medicine and all
that kind of stuff,
but I'm much more interested in talking
to you about,
uh,
global inequality.
I thought one things after sort of like
recently having had,
um,
Al Gore on the show for example,
and talking about huge issue like
climate change.
It's interesting,
I feel to listen to the framework within
which these conversations,
particularly conversations about
significant change at,
they take place within a sort of an
identifiable framework.
I wonder if you could talk to us,
give us a bit of an overview of global
inequality,
uh,
how it,
how things stand economically,
how we got into this position,
and then we'll crack on from there.
Well,
I suppose the place to start is what do
we presently think about global
inequality and what's kind of happening
in the world?
So there's,
there's actually a dominant narrative
out there that comes out of the World
Bank predominantly and gets repeated in
the media quite often that global
inequality on,
again,
a global scale is actually diminishing
along with globalization.
So we know for a fact that globalization
has caused inequality rates within
countries to get worse,
but the arguments from the World Bank is
that on a global scale,
it's getting better.
So the media picks us up.
Uh,
again,
this happened most recently,
a couple of years ago,
and argues that,
look,
globalization is actually good for the
poor of the world.
Uh,
you know,
it's working.
We should keep doing it because it's the
moral thing to do.
So what's interesting is if you look
behind those statistics,
you find that there are actually quite
misleading because a,
they think about global inequality,
um,
uh,
as if everybody in the world is part of
the same big country,
right?
And so on that basis,
it does appear that global inequality is
diminishing,
but only if you include China and East
Asia.
Now,
interestingly,
the,
that's the only part of the world that
has not been forcibly globalized,
um,
by the Washington consensus under US
pressure since the 1980s.
They basically,
uh,
transform their economies according to
their own standards.
So it doesn't really work to have the
narrative work that way.
Now,
and here's the crucial point.
If you look at global inequality between
regions of the world,
between say the global north and the
global south or rich countries versus
poor countries,
what we see is that rather than
diminishing global inequality is getting
dramatically worse since the 1960s,
uh,
the,
the per capita income gap between the
north and the south rich countries and
poor countries has tripled in size.
And that's really,
that's really a dramatic,
to me,
a dramatic condemnation of,
uh,
of globalization and pointing out that
it's just not working for the vast
majority of humanity.
Um,
the majority of,
of the yields of global capitalism are
going to rich countries.
I think that's a big problem.
I suppose in a way it would be obvious
that globalization would increase
inequality is globalization is a term
which really covers the power of
transnational corporations to have one
market place regulate it in a way that's
beneficial to them.
So it kind of makes sense that that
would mean that money was traveling in a
particular direction and it wouldn't be
beneficial to the poorest and most
vulnerable people.
How,
how are these myths sustained,
Jason?
These ideas like,
like trickle down economics and mass
production that the ultimately all in
it.
Like how,
how often have nearly a century,
uh,
or these kind of ideas sustained.
Is it kind of a form of propaganda and
the management it's the same stakes as
you've already mentioned?
Yeah.
Um,
first I just want to briefly touch on
what you mentioned just now with
trickled down.
So if you look at,
um,
at all of the new income generated by
global GDP growth over the past couple
of decades,
GDP,
gross domestic products basically
measured as the s the increasing size of
the global economy.
Um,
only 5% of all new income generated by
global growth has gone to the poorest
60% of humanity.
So that's an extremely slow rate of
trickle down.
Yeah.
It's barely trickling down at all.
It won't even get there.
It'll be a vapor by the time it's
halfway down.
That's exactly right.
Yeah.
And economists have pointed out that at
that rate of trickle down to eradicate
poverty from the face of the earth,
which is what we technically
theoretically want to be doing,
a would take over 200 years.
That's how slow it trickles down.
If there was any intention to actually
eradicate poverty,
this is not the means by which she would
do it,
then.
Okay.
That is definitely true.
And that's what,
that's basically the argument that I
make in my book,
the divide.
Um,
the reason to have intention to
eradicate poverty,
hobbies necessary is in it for the
global economic model.
Hey,
see,
you're an anthropologist,
doesn't ever,
apologies means study if she human
behavior.
Yes,
that's,
yeah,
that's anthropology.
Uh,
so my,
um,
my anthropological work is focused on a
particular part of the world that South
Africa.
I'm originally from Swaziland,
so it's quite close to where I'm from.
And again,
I look at patterns of migration and
exploitation in that region,
but uh,
but just I guess just by virtue of
having grown up in Swaziland and then
moving to the states from a university
and phd,
um,
you know,
I was really grappling with this
question of why are some countries so
immensely rich and consume so much while
other countries are so miserably poor
and have been for such a long time.
Uh,
so I guess that's the question of,
of why the is divided as it is
economically as really exercise me.
And that kind of led me on this really
10 or more your journey to,
to understand more about how the global
economy works and write that up in a way
that the average person can understand.
So the aspect of anthropology,
the interests you is the movement of
resources and capital.
And systems of dominance.
And after your decade of research
leading to this book of yours,
the divide,
what are your most important
observations?
And uh,
I'm glad that you said in a language
that anyone can understand cause I'm
anyone.
So can you put it in a,
tell us what your most important
observations are?
Well,
so I want to go back to the question
that you asked earlier about it's going
to be,
I'm going to ultimately answer the
question you just asked right now.
You mentioned this thing about
narrative,
right?
Uh,
what's the narrative that sort of keeps
the system chugging along?
And it was a brilliant question
actually.
So,
and I think that probably,
uh,
you know,
the,
the center of this narrative is that,
um,
you know,
rich countries have become rich based on
their own hard work and they have the
right policies and there's smart,
etc.
Etc.
Whereas poor countries or poor because,
uh,
you know,
they have internal policy failures.
Maybe they're corrupt me that maybe they
have bad climates,
not enough resources,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Um,
but rich countries a very generous and
what they do is they give generously of
their surplus across the divide to poor
countries to help them sort of a up the
development ladder.
And so we hear this all the time from
our politicians talking about the,
uh,
the international aid budget,
the foreign aid budget,
and on a global scale,
the foreign aid budget that flows from
rich countries to poor countries is
huge.
It's $130 billion per year right now.
That sounds like a lot of money.
And it is,
that's about the a,
the equivalent of all of the profits of
all of the commercial banks in the u s
combines,
uh,
that,
that goes from north to south every
year.
But,
um,
if you look at all the money that flows
around the world,
way more flows from south to north on an
order of magnitude,
then trickles the other way.
And I think that is really the,
uh,
the key point that we need to make here.
The aid is not flowing from north to
south.
It's flowing from south to north.
It's flowing in reverse.
So basically poor countries are
developing rich countries,
rich countries are not developing for
our countries,
so that they're the,
the,
that that flows from north to South East
contextualized his aid and that that
flows from south to north is content's
job contextualized as good business is
economics.
But really you would taste sort of post
colonial exploitation.
Yeah,
you can see it as,
as plunder or you can see it as tributes
and,
but he,
here's a really important fact.
So,
and this is actually quite recent data.
Uh,
so I guess it was a December or January,
um,
an an institute in Washington DC called
global financial integrity,
partnered with the Norwegian School of
economics to do the most comprehensive
study of financial flows around the
world ever conducted in the world,
uh,
in history.
And what they've found is that poor
countries are net creditors to rich
countries,
um,
uh,
to,
on such a scale that for every dollar of
aid that port can receive from which
countries,
uh,
they lose $24 in net outflows,
right?
I mean,
so basically the south is effectively
hemorrhaging to the north.
And this happens through all sorts of
flows,
like,
um,
illicit financial flows that basically
corporations stealing money out of poor
countries and s and storing them in tax
havens,
uh,
many of which are controlled by the
city.
London.
When you say stealing money,
what do you mean by what means?
Uh,
yeah,
so this,
there's a mechanism called,
uh,
called trade miss invoicing.
And basically the way this works is that
a company will,
uh,
we'll falsify it's trade invoices when
it's exporting goods out of a poor
country into a rich country.
Right.
Um,
and by doing that,
it can actually end up taking,
uh,
taking money offshore,
putting in a tax haven.
And it's very difficult for customers to
stop this.
Um,
it's a practice that's been legalized
basically by the WTO since 1994.
Um,
again,
and the WTO of course,
is controlled largely by rich countries
since they have the bargaining power.
So they were able to sort of establish
this rule,
which is deeply detrimental to poor
countries,
but he's like apparently neutral
governing and regulate.
We bodies are in fact,
in a way the administrative henchman of
a system of globalization.
It's based on exploitation of poor
countries.
Yeah,
that's a good way to put it.
I should write that in my next book.
Cancer.
Um,
yeah,
so you know,
so if you look at,
if you look at just illicit financial
flows alone,
uh,
then that's over 1 trillion US dollars
that flows from,
from poor to rich every year,
uh,
which outstrips the aid budget itself by
a factor of 10 a right.
And there's all sorts of all sorts of
other flows like,
um,
like the interest payments on foreign
loans that port companies have to pay,
um,
profit repatriation from multinational
companies,
uh,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
I suppose part of your point then,
Jason,
is that many of the systems that we
consider to be sort of objective and
just are kind of administrative
fictions,
perhaps the economy itself and even
something like a GDP,
it's just an idea.
It's not earn an objective reality.
Is that part of what you're saying mate?
Yeah,
no,
absolutely.
Uh,
and I'll definitely want to talk a bit
more about GDP and how that is a fiction
of our imagination that's become quite
destructive.
But,
um,
but just to,
just to go back to what you were saying
earlier about these admin administrative
bodies who Ronnie sketch sharing a
question.
Well,
you mentioned,
you mentioned these global
administrative bodies and it's not just
the WTO,
it's also like the World Bank and the
IMF.
So look at Netherlands,
those acronyms,
acronyms.
I've always fought IMF wb out of ways.
Like whenever I see stuff happening near
dodgy.
Oh they,
they are definitely dodged.
And here's the deal is that the World
Bank,
the international monetary funds are a,
are basically the institutions that
control the rules of the global economy
right now.
And here's the thing,
they're profoundly anti democratic
institutions.
So rich countries,
which have a minority of the population
of the world,
um,
half about 50% of the vote in these
institutions,
the u s government has a veto over all
major decisions made in these
institutions.
The whole thing's pointless anyway.
I mean,
yeah,
it's deeply,
it's a deeply compromised system.
I think it's a,
and for me,
you know,
the problem is primarily that it's
anti-democratic.
If you were to,
uh,
um,
you know,
open up the WTO and World Bank and
International Monetary Fund.
See real democratic practice doesn't
give poor countries a fair voice in how
the global economy is run.
Definitely we would see dramatic change.
Okay.
Shell oven buggering about with it.
So,
okay,
so that'd be a o Imf,
all those things I keep,
I know I'm listing boxing organizations
now called the mcgregor fight,
fill it bay where I say that.
Um,
hey,
give us some more of those statistics
there.
Sort of a mind boggling like,
uh,
like how can we,
how can a,
an ongoing narrative and narrative be
the depletion of poverty when you EGA
billion people are living on less than a
dollar a day.
And the one that saw voice clumps me in
the face when I read it,
the richest eight people in the world
control the same amount of wealth is the
poorest half of the world's fault.
That's a killer facts.
It's horrible.
Um,
so I want to go to the poverty number
that you just mentioned.
So,
and that sounds about Nicole.
She said,
I don't have a system now that's,
uh,
you know,
the world,
the World Bank and the UN are telling us
that,
uh,
the number of poor people in the world
is between 700 million and 1 billion
people basically right now.
Um,
and what they've been saying is that
that number has been decreasing over the
past 15 or so years.
Um,
because of their,
the way the good things that are doing
basically through aid and so on.
Um,
but if you look at how they measure
poverty,
uh,
there's a real problem at stake.
Um,
that that number comes from a poverty
line.
That's a dollar 25 per day right now.
Um,
scholars from all over the world have
been pointing out that nobody can live
on a dollar 25 a day.
It's a totally ludicrous,
immoral number.
Uh,
so in order to achieve the most basic
levels of human subsistence,
uh,
to achieve normal human life expectancy,
you know,
to have a decent chance of surviving
pastor fifth birthday,
etc.
Etc.
You have to have at least $5 per day,
right?
As like a moral minimum.
They called us the ethical poverty line.
Let me just get below that moral
minimum.
Exactly.
So here's the thing.
If you measure,
if you measure global poverty at that
level,
then it's not 1 billion people in
poverty.
It's 4.3
billion people in poverty,
which is 60% of the world's population
and the number has been getting bigger
over time,
not getting smaller.
And so again,
I think that the narrative that we have,
um,
that comes out of some of these bodies
that don't worry,
poverty is a diminishing and equalities
diminishing is just not true.
And if you look at the scholarship
behind it,
we see exactly the opposite story.
And so we really have to ask ourselves,
why is the global economy is so
fundamentally flawed?
This to fix this problem,
to make it fair,
um,
is going to require more than just
tweaking around the edges of the bit of
aid here and there,
uh,
but rather fundamentally reorganizing
the system.
How on Earth,
what will you fundamentally reorganized
system when the system is clearly
beneficial to the people that control
it?
That's a good question.
So,
so,
um,
you know,
I guess you can think about it this way,
um,
in terms of is this possible or not?
Uh,
so I have lots of students,
a lot,
a lot of my students come in like,
you know,
deeply concerned about poverty and
inequality and so on.
Um,
and they get really interested in,
in,
uh,
in solutions like,
you know,
micro finance or foreign aid or whatever
it might be.
Um,
uh,
but the problem is that the solutions
that they're interested in don't
actually target the real structural
causes of the problems that they are so
concerned to address.
If we can,
if we can get messages out to,
to,
to these students who fill the
development industry and all the
development organizations that are out
there that are trying to tackle these
problems,
that what we need is to tackle these,
the,
the real deep structural drivers that
causes the problem in the first place.
Uh,
then,
um,
then you know,
the problem can be solved relatively
quickly.
Go on.
Uh,
um,
so,
you know,
I mentioned one of the,
one of the top solutions for me it would
be,
it would be democracy and the
institutions of global governance.
So,
um,
and they're all sorts of proposals out
there.
I mean,
this is demand at that global south
countries have been making for a long
time for a fair,
for fair reason.
Cause I never hear those arguments so
that they're afraid is that been going?
Can we have a bit of democracy in these
world governance organizations?
And that message just never gets it
fair.
It never gets tired.
Um,
yeah.
So,
you know,
I think that there's all sorts of other
interesting ones.
Like for example,
um,
there's a huge wage differential between
workers and the global north and workers
in the global south.
Um,
and a lot of that is due to the fact
that multinational companies can move
around the world looking for the
cheapest possible labor.
The workers can't move across borders as
freely right now,
which is horrible.
So what that means is that workers on
the path to try to compete with each
other to drive their own wages down.
Ah,
and that's really been,
it's horrible
Gyn.
That's a horrible,
this Dystopian,
it is already living in this type.
Yeah.
We are in the global north luckily.
So that's something,
yes.
I suppose a,
although it's not totally clear to me
that we really deserve our privileges
here
and also we are not part of those eight
people that have got off of everything
our years,
sadly not.
So like as you say,
it's deep structural change like that.
Like when I was talking to Al Gore who
was absolutely lovely,
a lot of people said talking at our golf
around fairly in my view like that.
My main point was how can you have
significant change within a context that
is designed to prohibit real change.
And once when Yanis Varoufakis was here,
he said,
he said that,
you know that wolf gang showers at him
democracies.
Okay.
As long as you don't change anything.
So as you are now saying,
Jason,
systemic change is what's required now.
What are the air like?
So what I feel like I want this podcast
to do is marshal people's attention into
the correct areas.
Instead of going,
no,
it would be nice to have some micro,
like your lovely students coming in on
day one and they're big lovely scarves
and their rosy cheeks or full of
optimism.
Instead of that saying,
well,
what is it?
What ideas should we be pushing?
What should we be campaigning for?
Nave mentioned democracy at the level of
global,
uh,
of institutions that glove govern global
finance as one thing.
Okay.
We've remembered that.
What else?
So in order to really understand what's
at stake here,
I think that we have to understand how a
global inequality came to be as extreme
as it as it is right now.
Right?
So we needed like some of the historical
perspective there.
Okay,
I'll handle this one.
A lot of people are very,
very lazy.
Then there's countries,
European countries where we really were
an industrious bunch and we crack shot.
I've got a lot of things done.
Now is there an alternative version?
So the alternative version is that we
might want to start with colonialism,
right?
Um,
and if you want to look for sort of like
the origins of it,
of mass poverty,
it really is.
It really is under colonialism,
which was basically a process of mass
displacement of peasants from the land
and,
uh,
and a total wreckage of a,
of local economies.
Um,
so we know for a fact that during,
during the colonial period,
uh,
in most regions,
um,
income growth,
real income growth per capita was about
only 0.5%
per year for the entire colonial period.
Uh,
meanwhile,
as a result of colonialism,
um,
rich countries like Britain,
uh,
got to grow at a more than three times
that much.
And so that was a major driver of
inequality.
But he,
but here's the interesting point.
It,
and if you want,
we can go back to colonials and at some
point.
But,
um,
but in the wake of colonialism in the
two decades after colonialism ended in
19,
in the 1950s,
in 1960s,
there was a complete miracle in the
global south.
Um,
you know,
they suddenly had a democracy and they
had control over their own economic
policies.
And what did they do?
They elected leftist progressive leaders
and they brought in tariff protections
to protect their markets from a cheap
goods from abroad.
They,
uh,
they nationalized their own resources.
They nationalized,
uh,
a lot of big companies and banks,
um,
you know,
the increased labor standards,
they,
they redistributed land from rich land
owners to peasants.
And with these policies,
they were remarkably successful.
Would you mind telling us,
I mean,
it was all over the global south,
but you can,
you can see it,
I guess most,
uh,
most clearly I suppose in Latin America.
I mean,
look at what's happening in,
uh,
in Chile and Brazil and Uruguay.
You can also see it,
and I'm in parts of the Middle East,
like Egypt's in East Asia,
this is very clear as well.
Um,
so
unshackled from colonialism found its
way towards policies,
socialism,
nationalism,
redistribution of wealth,
management of trade and I suppose
systems that we're focused on.
People rather than profit broad.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And they,
and they were using,
and they were using their,
their national wealth to invest in
things like education and health care.
And so,
as you can imagine,
you know,
poverty starts diminishing and the gap
between rich countries and poor
countries starts closing for the first
time in history.
It was really a kind of miracle.
And you think that rich countries,
since I always go on about wanting to
develop poor countries,
it'll be very excited about this trends.
Right?
Finally,
you know,
there's success and poverty is reducing,
but quite the opposite actually what we
see is that,
um,
rich nations feel that they're losing
their access to cheap labor and cheap
raw materials and the global south.
Uh,
and so,
you know,
the,
the access they'd enjoyed under
colonialism and so they start
intervening,
uh,
violently by deposing a lot of these
progressive leaders,
you know.
So I remember reading all those about
those leaders.
They're a horrible bunch.
Yeah.
Globalization's just colonization by
another name.
Um,
yeah,
I suppose.
Yeah.
Um,
but you know,
what's interesting is that a,
is that,
you know,
the,
the series of coups that started
unfolding,
um,
led by Britain and the US and France and
Belgium.
What were we doing?
We were funding who's very rear,
either overthrowing leaders in the
global south ourselves or we were
funding movements to overthrow them or
we were just supporting right wing
dictatorships to prevent a democratic
revolutions from happening and the froth
and really love it.
Barry,
go get,
as I say,
we are in the global north,
so I suppose it,
wow,
that's a fascinating,
I didn't know that that's how they can,
a very short period of time postcolonial
Lee economic disparity was decreased
because people obviously acted in a kind
of a national self interest,
not this sort of rampant individualism
and inequality producing systems that we
have grown to know and love.
But these are about all of these regions
where pretty much successfully the
stabilized in that that movement was
quashed.
Right.
Well,
the other movement was quashed,
but it wasn't actually by the cous.
Cous cous took a really big tall,
right.
And the most famous of these is the coup
against Salvador Allende in Chile in
1973.
And you can watch footage of it on
youtube actually,
bizarrely.
But,
uh,
but so even despite these interventions,
the global south was still rising
through the 70s.
Okay.
Um,
but then,
and,
and the global north in the form of the
g seven literally sat down around
tables,
leaders of the g seven sat there aren't
done round tables to figure out how to
stop this movement.
The movement was called Developmental
Wisdom,
uh,
and,
and it was very successful and,
uh,
and they couldn't figure out ways to
sort of block this because it was
becoming very powerful in the halls of
the UN,
which was a democratic body,
global south countries.
We're winning a new policies that were
fairer for them basically.
Um,
so,
but then in 1980,
the tables turned dramatically in a
single crazy events that changed the
global order in one fell swoop.
And that was the third world debt
crisis.
So basically the,
the U S Federal Reserve jacked up
interest rates,
um,
uh,
you know,
to really high levels,
like 20% and global south countries,
we're heavily indebted,
um,
in US dollars.
They suddenly were not able to pay their
debts back because of the interest rate
hike.
And they slid to the brink of default
now.
And if they,
if they were going to default,
Wall Street would have basically
collapsed.
And so Wall Street talked to the u s
government and said,
please,
you need to bail us out.
You need to solve this problem.
The US government talk to the IMF and
said,
you are going to go and roll over the
debts of those developing countries,
uh,
on the condition that they adopt what we
call structural adjustment programs,
which basically means liberalize your
trade,
uh,
cut your labor rules,
cut your environmental regulations,
uh,
privatized your companies and your
assets,
um,
uh,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Well,
Naomi Klein's it was about in shock
doctrine is unit that the sort of basic
policies lead to destabilization.
If those regimes just one putting on a
pick up on that Jason and see that 20%
hike by the Federal Reserve,
was that part of the scheme?
How can they get that?
So that was not exactly part of the
scheme actually that had to do with um,
with a domestic problem in the u s at
the time.
So the US was suffering with what we
call stagflation,
um,
start closure to doctor Tracy,
who's Mrs is involved,
will know our culture.
Well I'm embarrassed.
It was basically high levels of
inflation but low levels of growth.
And so they had to figure out some way
to,
to increase levels of growth again,
because the rich people were really
upset that they weren't,
they weren't gaining,
uh,
you know,
a fair income share.
And so they figured out that they could,
if they raised interest rates,
it would basically cause a recession in
the u s it would empty out the,
is break the back of the labor unions,
which are very powerful at time and a
and decrease the price of labor which
has succeeded in doing,
um,
and as a result of the cost of labor in
the u s has not risen since 1980,
if you can imagine that.
So it was,
it was to solve a domestic political
problem,
but I had these ramifications around the
world that changed the way the world
works for ultimately for the benefit of
the same interests.
No,
because the Wall Street said to IMF,
go roll over these lounge.
They said,
we'll do it.
As long as you adopt these systems that
are amenable to our world view and
everyone's cushy jobs or garden,
you're very good at describing these
things in a way that,
uh,
I can understand because I understood
that justin now good.
I'm angry about it.
What we're going to do.
Um,
yeah,
I'm hungry too.
And a lot of guys,
I would say most people in the world
angry.
And you know,
it's interesting as the people were so
angry that they took to the streets and
masses,
right?
So this,
so these structural adjustment programs
cut like caused per capita income growth
rates to collapse from a high of 3.2%,
which was really high for the south down
to 0.7%.
Basically economic crisis,
right?
In Africa,
we start incomes actually decline over a
decade or more.
I mean,
this,
this caused millions of people to be
pushed into poverty.
It was a complete travesty.
Uh,
it was the greatest single cause of
poverty,
um,
uh,
in the 20th century after colonialism.
So people understandably took to the
streets,
um,
uh,
in what we called IMF riots,
you know,
but what's,
what's interesting is that,
you know,
and they complained to their
governments,
they were like,
look,
you know,
stop these austerity policies.
Basically that's what they are.
Um,
you know,
we want to go back to the fair economic
policies we had before.
Um,
but here's the thing is that global
south countries themselves,
the governments themselves couldn't do
anything about it because control of our
macro economic policymaking in,
uh,
in these countries had been shifted to
bankers and technocrats in Washington,
in New York.
Right?
And so in fact,
structural adjustment had worked as a
kind of bloodless coup,
if you will,
in one fell stroke almost.
They were able to establish effective
control over economic policymaking
processes in the global south.
So in a sense,
democracy at their level of a state
level was irrelevant and redundant
because the economic strings are held
elsewhere.
And brought,
you just said there,
Jason,
about economics,
the economics,
he's not some objective sciences.
Yanis Varoufakis anywhere in there.
And as I'm learning from you,
it's just a model for man for
maintaining inequality that all of these
systems are all trouble by certain
people.
Some people are allowed to shift the
rules,
change rules,
some people aren't.
And it's a way of continually managing
power.
Yeah,
exactly.
I think that's so important to
understand is that is that flows of,
of resources and wealth around the world
all have to do with the rules of the
global economy and who gets to set those
rules.
Right.
So,
um,
in,
in the 1980s,
basically beginning then is when a power
over these rules was centralized and in
Washington,
in New York,
at the World Bank and in Wall Street and
the IMF,
we've got to get rid of with them every
well,
you know,
and what's,
I mean personally,
yes,
I do believe that.
Um,
and I don't think that's a radical
position actually since,
um,
most people in the global south have
made the same demands for a long time.
Uh,
why can't,
I'm sorry for asking questions that 12
year old to ask,
why can't the like some of those
countries in the globe which have to go
in and pay in that stuff?
No more like these are what happened
with Greece.
Is that what they did?
They went because you were just saying
pain.
You mate,
why can't you do that?
No,
I think that's such a good question
because the other option the global
south countries had,
instead of submitting the structural
adjustment would have been to just
default on their loans.
Right now there's,
there's some problems with that.
A,
um,
in the 1980s,
uh,
somebody tried.
Okay.
And this is,
this is such an inspiring story.
Um,
there's a guy named Thomas Sankara.
He was the president,
the revolutionary president of Burkina
Faso,
a west African country.
He was a young man.
He was a brilliant social reformer.
He was considered the Shag with our of
Africa.
Cool mate.
And you can listen to his speeches
online.
They're amazing.
He's really an inspiring guy.
Thomas Sankara.
Yeah.
And Thomas Sankara as president of
Burkina Faso stood up in the halls of
the African Union.
Um,
in the early 1980s,
I went to say,
and,
uh,
and he gave his famous speech against
debt.
He said,
um,
you know,
comrades,
basically debt is a form of
neocolonialism.
It means that the west gets to control
what happens,
uh,
in terms of economic policy in our
countries.
And this is what he said.
He said,
here's the thing about debt.
Uh,
if you do not pay it,
nobody dies.
We surely die.
And it was interesting cause the room
electrified and he basically like
started a kind of a revolution against
the debt,
right?
And three months later he was
assassinated in a French backed coup.
So,
and so here's the thing is that,
is that it does it for Thomas.
He's a good looking guy too,
I have to say.
All right.
Then she's come up with a brilliant
bloody revolution against that.
But when we would have a look at him in
a minute,
oh,
he sounds like a bloody hero.
So a lot of these terms.
Right.
That's interesting.
So like,
like I like that there is a sort of a,
another way of crow barring sort of
colonialism in to the mix.
When I was thinking about like,
you know,
these rules,
people think about these rules.
He's economic rules that dominate global
trade,
global trade and the flow of resources
around the world as a sort of objective.
But they are of course determined by the
powerful.
So we should look very carefully at
these non national transcendent global
organizations such as the IMF and other
things I keep thinking of of wrestling
organizations because they are set in
the structures that mean that change is
impossible.
Another thing that just occurred to me
is when people say like,
you know,
what's the answer?
Redistribution of wealth.
But redistribution of wealth,
what's been happening all along the
wealth of the south has been
redistributed,
uh,
north.
And of course this isn't just happening
on a global level.
It's happening on the level of caste and
class within each of these countries
because there's loads of people.
Of course you look out this window here
in London,
Leicester Square,
and you'll see people that are in the
globe and global norm and it ain't going
to well for their mind or they're
sleeping out there on those streets.
Now.
Like I suppose really what's required is
an ideological shift.
That's the,
you know,
the,
the self corrective measures that were
applied in some of the countries in the
70s that brought about that economic
miracle on a national level of
socialism,
nationalization and our protective trade
tariffs.
It's almost like at this point,
we need a way of,
excuse me,
presenting those kind of ideas on what
our global level or just popularizing
the idea so perhaps parties could run on
them.
Cause I saw him,
I was doing it now after what happened
with [inaudible] in Greece and you know,
like,
and sort of what's happening in this
country of Jeremy Corbyn or Bernie
Sanders in the,
in the USA.
I sometimes think,
well,
if the,
you did have a lead like Corbyn got in,
would these global institutions prevent
real change from being enacted?
What day?
Yeah.
Um,
well,
are you going to answer a question from
this morning?
I suppose,
yeah,
I suppose one of the most important
interventions,
um,
is to cancel the debts.
And I really mean that.
I don't mean like let's,
let's forgive some ducks,
which suggests like somehow they sins
raw these debts anyway.
Well,
so that's,
um,
most of them actually were accumulated
during the 1970s after the oil,
after the oil crisis in 1973.
Um,
basically what it meant is that in order
to,
uh,
to fund their own consumption in global
south countries had to borrow tons of
money because the price,
the price of oil was so high.
Um,
and so a lot of these deaths are
actually still hanging around since 1972
some even older than that.
And because of the miracle of compound
interest,
many of them have been paid,
paid off many times over already,
and yet they're still paying them off.
And so it's kind of this,
I mean,
it's,
it's a problem in two ways.
Uh,
it's kind of a flow.
It's like a flood of cash that goes from
poor countries directly to banks.
Mostly in rich countries.
Um,
and the other thing is that means that
that governments don't have effective
control over their own policymaking.
Economical.
So if you cancel it,
that's a,
in a,
in a radical way,
which would require of course,
um,
global south countries getting together
to resist a debt to refute,
to collectively refused repayments.
You know,
they can't assassinate them all at the
same time that we look bad,
bad,
right.
Then,
uh,
then you know,
then you free,
then countries are freed up to pursue
policies.
Fellows like you don't want the nor for
the,
you know,
canceling them.
You just want a sound guy.
We ain't paying him.
That is,
it's not,
we're not Bam,
you canceling or not,
we're canceling them.
We're just not paying it.
That's sort of what's required now I
suppose what historically what the panel
have been,
I've been,
as you say,
the assassination of people that propose
those kinds of measures and the
replacement with regimes that are
friendly to the objectives if the,
the,
the institutions that continue to
benefit.
So what was I suppose like interesting
is whether or not new alliances can be
made,
because I feel sort of naturally more of
an affinity with the people that would
be canceling that rather than the debt
is,
even though I'm,
you know,
here in the lovely studio in the global
north and I'm doing pretty well.
Yeah.
And I think that that's maybe
increasingly true because if you look at
the number of people who have student
debt in the u s I mean that's a,
that's $1 trillion of student debt right
there.
They also realize that there was a real
problem with the debt system.
Uh,
and if,
if you,
if you can start building sort of at
least conceptual alliances across,
um,
across these different classes of
debtors and I think that you can,
you can sort of free yourself to imagine
a world without it canceled debt.
Yeah,
exactly.
Where resistant.
Yeah.
One of the things I was thinking again
with ankle,
we're just like that like with we are
prioritizing economic systems,
which are fictions of fabrications,
certainly concepts that have been
created by mankind with firing them over
actual factual material,
physical things like the planet and
meteorological systems.
And again,
with all this,
like with what you're saying about debt
management and trade manipulation,
some countries have resources,
so like how has the country like Africa
that it's mineral rich or like Latin
America,
we've all of its agriculture and
minerals,
how were they poor?
If you can produce those things,
then that's it.
You've produced those things.
Sure.
We clearly what's required is like on
one level they a different way of
looking at economics on a global basis,
but that's going to mean the obviously
what that does is it challenges the
interests of the people that are in
control of the system as it currently
stands.
So ultimately you arrive at a point,
don't you,
Jason,
where what is required?
It's not an like you've said these
things out loud.
Now these ideas are out there,
so what do you do?
You popularize these ideas.
At what,
where does the rubber meet the road?
Is our American coffin say,
where does it become like,
well,
we're not doing this,
we're not doing that.
We're going to shut down this.
We're going to shut down that who is the
enemy?
Who Do we target?
Where do I stand or do we do?
Um,
yeah,
that's a good question.
I'm not sure I'm going to,
I guess we could brainstorm right now,
but,
but for me,
um,
you know,
the important first step is to free
ourselves of these false narratives
about aid and development that we have
right now.
You know,
the right,
good.
Done.
Yeah.
So,
um,
and then,
uh,
and again,
you know,
uh,
debt cancellation I think is essential
democratizing the world system.
The central,
I was going to mention earlier,
I was going to mention the importance of
a fairer international wage system.
So,
um,
you know,
again,
wages in the south are much lower than
in the north,
if you,
you know,
and it's possible actually to,
to bring in a kind of global minimum
wage system.
It would be governed by the UN through
the International Labor Organization.
And you would set the minimum wage at
50% of each country median wage and
basically,
uh,
you would eradicate working poverty,
pretty much overnights.
Um,
and this proposal's been made by number
of economists.
We know that there's a system in place
that's capable of handling it.
What's the counter argument?
Why do people say you can't do that by,
that would lead to it.
What is their argument for why you can't
do stuff like that?
Oh,
I guess there are going to be that's um,
you know,
uh,
well I guess I guess proper new liberals
that say you should never regulate
wages.
Um,
but,
but here's the way that I see it,
right?
If we're going to have a system where,
uh,
where capitalism is globalized,
then it only stands to reason that we
need a system where the rules that
regulate capitalism or also globalized.
So,
um,
I guess that's the way that I would,
so if you have global free movement of
capital,
you need global free movement of way,
uh,
of workers.
If you have global capitalism,
you need global regulation if the way
that people are paid.
So it's a really biased,
messed up system.
Tell me about like,
just having a look at some of the bogey
man of the system.
Who's benefiting from this?
What about companies like a big billy
Elo,
sue's superior,
a transnational companies like apple,
uh,
what's going on with them?
Haven't you got some sort of terrible
thing to tell us about them?
Um,
yeah,
I mean,
I guess,
I guess apple is only one of many
companies that,
uh,
that only really exists because they're
able to,
uh,
to exploit very cheap labor and the
global south.
Um,
and you know,
at some point I think,
um,
trump even said to the CEO of apple,
you know,
you need to bring these factories back
home.
It was a trump or maybe somebody else.
And he was like,
look,
these factors are not going back home.
Basically.
Apple cannot come,
has no business model.
Oh.
Unless we've got little bullies mining
in Africa,
like I looked at,
we saw we'd made a,
like a,
an episode of the it on a news thing.
We do.
And it was when it Gareth,
it was that some,
some just arse achingly terrible thing
about little children are mining for
this results that's in your iphone.
And he sort of watch it and think,
oh bloody hell.
It like you sort of unimaginable uh,
in a dry,
what do I want to say?
Sort of negligence,
cruelty,
irresponsibility that we don't really
countenance when you hold an apple
iphone or an ipad in your hand,
you don't think and you're encouraged
not to think of what the consequences of
that are.
And for,
and like we're,
because I haven't,
we already been bread and inculcated to
think as consumers,
you know,
I think it would be very difficult for
me as an individual,
although I am willing to do it to get to
let go of,
you know,
this product or that product,
this privilege,
that privilege people continually.
If you're,
if you're not sort of basically homeless
or living in a commune people,
so why don't you give up your call and
then what did you can about this then
don't you go at that?
And,
and I think these things are all valid
arguments as part of a sort of a
mobilization of significant change.
But you can see that any gestural move
from any individual is of little value
unless there's a sort of targeted
change.
One of the things I read once in
adbusters that I really liked were
saying like pick a couple of
corporations to really target and
annihilate that,
you know,
sort of saying like if you,
you could sort of like they,
they've,
they outlined how a few corporations are
hugely transgressed.
General Motors with their irresponsible,
you know,
not recalling cars that they knew were
killing people because it works out
economically better to leave them out
there and pay the lawsuits or Phillip
Morris knowing for years that their
tobacco is killing people.
Or even what you're saying there like a,
you know,
a big friendly and attractive
organization like Apple Look,
you know,
whose products I own and use and will
use within the hour.
You know,
like,
and people will be listening to this
podcast on those phones.
You know,
we are all participating in it,
but we're participating from this
position.
It seems,
Jason of impotence.
And like I feel that because they are
really what we ended up discussing here
isn't narratives the way that stories
are told,
but we don't think it's possible to have
significant change unless we come up
ourselves with stories,
ideas,
objectives that are accessible and
attractive.
Change won't happen.
I don't know how to sort of start,
you know,
getting people out on the streets,
banging a drum to bloody demetra,
democratize the IMF.
I don't know how to make people do that.
I,
you know,
like,
or interest people in that even,
uh,
you know,
here's the way that I think about it.
Um,
I guess I,
I guess first of all,
uh,
you know,
this idea of,
of seeing about changing our own
personal consumption habits,
I think that is important.
But what's much more important is that
we organize collectively to create a
system in which it's not,
it's not possible in the first place
that apple can be exploiting workers
like that.
Right.
Um,
you know,
so we need to kind of collective
solidarity before we just need personal
responsibility.
Um,
so,
uh,
do you feel collective solidarity with,
you know,
do you feel that as a man,
do you feel if that's something that you
experienced,
you're an anthropologist or an
economist,
you're teaching young people about this
stuff,
even though you're only 34 years old,
you're like some sort of gorgeous boy
band professor,
sorry to objectify you,
but you did it to that man in Africa.
So unlike,
you know,
so do you feel the sense that this kind
of solidarity,
I'm even now watching a man who I
imagined from Latin America emptying out
garbage here at global,
uh,
and let you know,
like,
and,
and you know,
this is everywhere.
This is all around us.
This is us.
And you know,
the,
I find it very difficult to get purchase
to understand how,
what shall I do now then?
And I think there is a real appetite.
I think the sort of,
the surprising result of the last
election for the success of Bernie
Sanders to a degree.
I like all these things,
points of people's appetite for change.
And like it's only the fact that stories
like,
you know,
I grew up like when our garages for old
at that coup in Nicaragua and you know,
and Bloody Pinochet and all that,
you just think that's how things are
meant to be out.
It's got to be,
I even like the struggle in Ireland,
I sort of grew up with the view your
spouse to have,
you know,
it's like,
it's very difficult to get these stories
out there.
How do we emotionally engage people
around sort of economic arguments that
always feel abstract cause they are
bloody abstract.
Unless you're a little kid mine in for
some minerals somewhere.
Yeah.
No,
I think that's absolutely right.
We need better and more powerful and can
more convincing stories.
I mean,
think about the power of the existing
development narrative.
So we need something that will tear that
apart,
but also,
uh,
you know,
create a rival to it.
Right.
And the thing is,
you know,
there's no question that,
that,
that we are more inspiring and more
convincing.
And the thing is,
you know,
I can see it in my,
in my own students,
right?
Like they all went to change the world.
They have these little ideas about aid
and microfinance.
It w as soon as you explained to them
how the world actually works in terms of
the global economy,
uh,
and point them in the direction of real
structural change.
There are so excited about that.
And now imagine if the millions of,
uh,
of people in Britain who are part of gap
years and other like student development
projects or NGOs,
uh,
and the hundreds of billions of dollars
that are in the industry.
Imagine if that was channeled in to
making the world fair.
I mean,
it would change radically,
radically and dramatically and would not
require a single drop of additional
foreign aid,
uh,
in order to eradicate poverty and
inequality.
So it seems like it'd be nice to have
like a little five point plan of five
things that would radically change the
world,
right?
You go right,
here are five ideas that if these things
were implemented were radically changed
the world.
And then the next thing you'd hear is
the people whose interests are currently
being served,
telling you aggressively,
repeatedly why these things won't work
and what,
and then,
you know,
probably about time issue personally say
that you're mad and you don't ever,
you know,
write to express those kinds of
opinions,
all sorts of stuff that happened.
But it'll be good to distill it down to
five simple things.
So what are some of those ideas you were
saying?
Massive debt cancellation or for
everybody cancel all that.
That's a really cool one.
I'd like that.
And let's get rid of my mortgage.
I'm in and like,
and like,
um,
and um,
what's the,
what are some of the other ones at
global minimum wage of 50% of that
national median.
Absolute.
That was a good one.
Yeah.
That we're aiming for now.
We of a few more cause it literally
tried to organize a global revolution
during this podcast.
Oh,
cool.
So,
uh,
so in the,
in the second to last chapter of my
book,
I actually have in fact a list of
exactly five things we can do to change
the global economy.
It's allison.
So we've already talked about a lot of
them.
We have debts,
we have counseling debt,
we have the,
the changing the wage system.
Um,
we have democracy,
democratizing global governance of
economic policy.
Um,
I think that there,
there are easy ways we can,
we can change the international trade
system to make it much fair to poor
countries as well.
So,
you know,
right now,
for example,
you know,
right now,
uh,
because of the WTO is your way around,
which came into effect in 1990 is a
global south countries are losing on
average 700 billion US dollars in
potential GDP per year because of
imbalances in the,
in the WTO trading structure.
So,
and that's seven times more than they
receive an aid,
right?
So this is a major cause of Glen Mullen
and 80 relevant.
It is completely irrelevant.
So in the book I lay out ways that we
can change the trade system.
Um,
and then also I think that a really
crucial one here is thinking about
climate change.
Because here's the deal.
We know for a fact that the vast
majority of historical emissions,
uh,
70% of them in fact have come from,
from industrialized countries in the
West.
Okay.
But the vast bulk of the consequences of
climate change are hitting the global
south really,
really dramatically,
uh,
through wildfires,
droughts,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Um,
so,
and,
and as a result of climate change,
Global South countries are losing in the
region of $500 billion per year in terms
of losses and,
uh,
you know,
which again outstrips the aid budget by
a factor of five there.
So we needed,
we need much more rigorous action on
climate change to,
uh,
to,
um,
to get rich countries to reduce that
points point to all the,
all of these proposed regulations mean
that powerful economic interests will be
curved and confronted.
Can you imagine them ever like,
like sort of history sort of looks to me
like at a glance,
and that's all I've ever given it.
Like a saw a struggle between the
powerful and the powerless with the
powerful conceding the bare minimum
amount of power.
They can concede everything.
Oh,
bloody hill.
Women want the vote.
All right,
we can't have slavery anymore.
Oh,
right,
okay.
Let me in.
They just stopped.
But they'll go hang onto it for as long
as they can and then give the minimum.
And in each case you would say,
well,
you know,
like here we are all these years after
suffrage and women is still exploited
and not paid as much as men in the
United States.
Look what's happening around race and
continues to happen around race.
So these things in a sense,
move slowly unless they're sort of
radical systemic change.
And do you think it's unlikely for
radical systemic change to be bought
around without force and death?
Um,
yeah.
So,
um,
I agree with you and I think that
basically the system we have right now
is a kind of global apartheid.
Uh,
and it's,
uh,
and,
and just as the anti apartheid struggle
in South Africa required,
um,
you know,
immense collective mobilization,
uh,
I think the same as going to be true of
the struggle.
We need to abolish global apartheid.
And,
uh,
we'll,
it's,
will it end up,
you know,
and conflicts.
Um,
it's definitely possible.
And historically when attempts have been
made to make the world fair,
then that has been the case.
Um,
but you know,
what,
what is promising is that,
uh,
is that people around the global south
are,
are increasingly conscious of how unfair
the system is to them.
And they are the majority of the world.
And,
and,
and the more and more that we include
them in our,
in our,
in our discussions and our,
in our discourse,
through the Internet,
through our media,
et cetera.
Um,
you know,
the more of this message is going to
come through.
But how do we galvanize some working
class white bloke in dunk cost r and d
day six,
you know,
because they similarly are suffering as
a result of this economic system.
But they're not going to start thinking,
oh are,
you know,
identify with some bloke in Chile,
how do you have a global movement?
You know,
like this isn't just happening in the
global south.
Like during the time that we've been
doing this podcast,
you know,
there's people probably minimum wage
worker.
Cause this is a business that I imagine
would not take the risk of paying people
below minimum wage,
although they'll probably outsourced to
a cleaning company that are using people
that have got,
knows how their document it or whatever,
you know,
to like say like this is not
hemispherically divided.
This is everywhere.
Yeah.
I think that's definitely true.
We can definitely see elements of the
south right here in the north.
There's no question about it.
Um,
and not just actually people from the
south who are suffering,
you know,
among us.
But uh,
but the same dynamics,
um,
uh,
of the south like,
you know,
slums and horrible health care,
health care conditions and so on are
present.
Right.
You know,
in global north countries themselves.
Yeah.
Cause you are an expert.
If I'm picking up from the intro online,
sort of f no graphic stuff.
Right.
And like,
but like in La,
so all this Charlotesville Lark,
it's call it last week,
you know that sort of like why you went
to university.
Can you imagine?
Kidding me.
Crazy.
So what do you think?
Right.
So what do you think about that?
I mean like,
you know,
like sort of for me,
once people start parading around
getting all Nazi,
that's sort of a clear indication.
They feel hugely the disempowered.
Like,
you know,
while people will say,
Oh,
you know,
under the sort of covered trump
administration,
people would feel it.
It's more a somehow acceptable to
express more extremist views that that
may be true.
But also those people must be feeling
something in order to do that.
You and nine know,
and most people know that what they're
targeting is incorrect and immoral,
but what they're feeling is real.
They are feeling something.
They're feeling anger,
right.
How do we reach those people?
Or do we just go home?
Forget it.
They're not as well,
you know,
I mean,
cause I didn't feel that way.
I feel like,
oh this is,
these people need help.
Yeah.
I mean,
I completely agree and I'm very torn
because on the one,
on the one hand,
you know,
I think that we absolutely have to fight
fascism wherever it rears its ugly head.
But on the other hand,
we do have to feel a kind of compassion
for,
uh,
at least,
at least for those who,
who reached these conclusions because
they feel immiserated are dispossessed
or something like that,
uh,
in,
in a legitimate sense.
Right.
Uh,
so,
so to the extent that there are people
who turn to these narratives,
these white nationalists narratives
because they feel that the system is
screwing them,
uh,
in some real sense because the system is
very unfair.
And let's be honest,
I think that absolutely we have to,
we have to work on building their
consciousness.
Um,
to the extent that these people have not
been misdirected,
but are nonetheless still racist pricks,
then we can't give them any of our
compassion.
That's,
I guess that's kind of the way I feel
about that.
Cause I don't let that,
you know,
like I don't know why the practice is
because I'm a white man.
But like I,
I feel like when that sort of stuff
happens and I look at their faces with
those torches,
he's weird stuff,
man.
And I feel like that we,
I feel we can't leave people behind.
I'm not suggesting,
you know,
it's obvious my allegiance lies.
We have people that aren't marching
around with torches.
But like I feel that unless you address
the resource rage,
the feeling,
unless people like get it goes well,
who should they be angry with?
Their unhappy.
I don't think you can get people a march
around in the streets of the taught
unless there's something really
seriously wrong,
you know,
enlightened.
Unless that's addressed then this we'll
reformulate and re manifest the way that
is clear over the course of our
conversation,
Jason,
that the exploitation that came with
colonization route simply re presented
as globalization that behind the mask
of,
uh,
the,
the previous national identity core per
identities,
we're able to continue the same
exploitation,
making little nods and gestures here or
there when it became impossible to not
do that.
But to make significant change,
you have to start dealing with what
people are feeling,
what's happening in people's hearts and
minds and spirits.
Cause he's really excellent to hear you
outline how these things have happened,
why they've happened,
and what would need to change in order
for significant redistribution or a
fairer society to a merge.
But like a tear,
unless people can be emotionally
engaged.
I don't see how that will happen because
I think most people will have a vague
idea.
Everything is corrupt.
Everything's,
you know,
you can't.
But I think people also feel broadly
impotent.
Um,
I think that another,
another thing we have to consider here
is that,
you know,
the,
the south might just take matters into
their own hands and already,
you know,
and I guess in a way,
like we're kind of irrelevant to the,
to the struggle.
I mean we in the West,
like we're obviously on the wrong side.
So,
uh,
so if you look like,
if you look at what's happening in the
south already,
you know,
you have in Latin America you have,
um,
a number of governments working together
to form kind of like,
uh,
like alternative trade networks that's,
um,
that are,
that are based on fair principles.
And,
um,
you know,
you have,
you have the rise of alternative
alternative institutions like the,
uh,
the brics bank and the Asian
Infrastructure Development Bank that are
trying,
that are to provide an alternative to
the International Monetary Fund and
render these,
these big global organizations
irrelevant right now.
We don't know if that's going to work or
if they're going to be instruments of
sort of sub imperial evil for the
countries that run them like China.
We don't know.
But uh,
but at least that's what people are
trying to do.
And there's some hope there I think
and perhaps behind these ideas.
I wonder,
it's like that when you were saying this
stuff,
like when do you think of it?
Right?
You know,
how we regard the global narrative like
oh no,
this is just the way things are.
Some countries have reached,
some countries are poor.
It's because we got our got our up off
our power,
our season invented the spinning Jenny
and then and then the Vdu and you know
behind sort of within this there are
sort of concurrent narratives around
things like Darwinism that underwrite
that kind of philosophy.
Survival of the fittest.
Life is a struggle for original season
and that's just a way it is the fittest
and the strongest and the best survive.
These are already sort of selective
narrativize patients.
If history,
the mechanism,
the mechanistic model of the planet,
the world is a bit like a machine
evolutions,
a bit like a machine selecting and
making binary choices like it's not as
we are a underwritten by that kind of
philosophy then why would we be
compassionate or why would any emergent
system not resort ultimately to like you
said,
a sub imperial or comparable trend,
you know like setting up some rival
economic model that China's involved in.
I don't know much about China but
there's like,
I don't look to me like their friends
over there,
fred in flowers for each other's air and
giving each other massages.
It looks like they could be a pretty
leery bunch as well if it all ever kicks
off.
So unless like,
you know,
where are the resources for these rules,
where,
where are we going to come up with a,
from where do we reach inside of
ourselves and find a philosophy by which
we can legitimately live and call
ourselves human and call ourselves
brothers and sisters and custodians of
this planet.
You know,
we're what is going to be the resource
and this is the bit where I go.
It's spirituality.
I think that's,
I think that's actually so important.
Uh,
I think that we have,
we have to start realizing that we are
all connected,
um,
that you know,
that we're brothers and sisters.
I think that's so essential in it
sounds,
it sounds so silly to say it.
That's because we've been taught to
think it's all silly so that people can
crack on and exploit everyone who don't
say that to lead to be broken and
sisters right now shut up.
You know,
cause you're an individual.
If globalization has done anything good
for us,
uh,
um,
it's,
it's the globalization of our sense of
connection.
And,
um,
you know,
I think that that,
uh,
you know,
we're,
we're definitely more aware of each
other right now.
And,
um,
I think that,
yeah,
we need,
we need to realize that,
uh,
in order for us to,
to create a world where,
where we are,
we're able to eradicate poverty,
um,
we need to learn how to share.
I think that's so fundamental because
the narrative that we'd been sold from
people in power is that the only way to
eradicate poverty is through GDP growth.
Right?
But we know that on a limited planet,
which is what we live on a and in an era
of rapid climate change,
continued GDP growth is not an option.
So without,
without growing the GDP and having some
of it trickled down to the poorest,
how are we going to eradicate poverty?
The only way to do it is to share what
we already have more fairly.
And that's gotta be a realization for
us.
None of us want to live in a world
that's marked where 60% of the human
population isn't.
It is in poverty.
Right?
Uh,
if you talk to the average bloke on the
street,
they're not going to want that.
Uh,
and so the key is,
is to realize what's necessary for us to
create an alternative world.
And that really is sharing.
Uh,
and that's exactly the opposite kind of
narrative to the one that we've been fed
all of our lives.
That's right.
And it's been underwritten again by
different aspects of science and
philosophy.
Darwinism.
Is it like a survival of the fittest and
not suggesting that evolution isn't
real?
Of course it is.
It's empirically and provably and
demonstrable.
He will,
but the implication that we should be
competing with one another for resources
is there sort of,
that's conjecture.
That's just an idea at different idea
will be,
we should be sharing that we are here
together,
that our life is individuals is not as
important as our life as a community.
Gout,
what did you hold up a question?
Just their mate.
What was it?
And this is a question,
Jason,
I've just thought up with using my
brilliant little brain.
Is there any hope within current global
power structures?
Are there any good guys,
any we can look to optimistically?
Um,
don't feel obliged to say me.
That's all.
I think there's some interesting people,
you know,
I was talking about structural
adjustment earlier.
Crucially,
those exact same policies that were
imposed on the south in the 1980s are
now being imposed all over southern
Europe.
Right.
And Greece of course,
is the,
uh,
the key example of this.
Um,
uh,
so Greece is being structurally adjusted
for the sake of bailing out French and
German banks.
Basically the same thing that happens in
the 1980s for the south and a so,
and so you have the emergence of a,
of resistance there.
And the form is the result,
or at least it was I kind of resistance
and Yanis Varoufakis and skate.
That dude's cool.
He's a cool guy.
Yeah.
And I,
I like what he has to say.
Um,
but it's not just him.
There are also people,
you know,
elsewhere in the south.
I think that,
uh,
I'm the President of Columbia,
create a gang
global crusaders,
a bit like the marvel avengers franchise
and I'm in it as well.
And we will go round coming up with
brilliant ideas and then that means of
going into manic trances,
preaching it all around the world.
Yes,
I definitely want to do that.
This whole soap speaking him Shamana
chanting.
I really liked the point you made about
spirituality and a,
and this is why,
because I feel like,
look right now the,
the levels of consumption that we enjoy
in the West are completely,
uh,
are completely based on extraction and
plunder in the south.
They depends on the immiseration of
people,
uh,
in,
in poor countries.
Now I think that that actually probably
plays really,
really badly for our sense of psyche and
our inner wellbeing.
I think that none of us want to live in
a world like that where deep inside we
know that every,
the,
the things we consume in the privilege
that we have depends on the suffering of
other people.
I think it makes us all like deeply
anxious on some even unspoken level.
Even if you don't acknowledge it.
And so,
you know,
in order to have a kind of inner
healing,
we have to,
we have to live in a world where our
daily actions are not creating misery
and the rest of the world.
That's beautiful.
We'd need to become conscious.
We need to become awake.
We need to think,
how happy is that phone making me?
How happy are these trainers making me
become aware?
Don't be distracted.
Don't lose your connection.
Connect to who you really are.
Any books you weren't going to recommend
for us.
Obviously your book,
which is called the divide,
a brief guide to global inequality and
it solution brief a,
it's very,
uh,
it's basically this,
my bangs right on.
Then it,
how many pages?
Um,
it's like 340.
I think that includes and notes and
stuff.
You'd have to read those bone.
I'm going to tear it out as soon as I
get it,
that whole bit of the back.
I'm not hearing it right to a copy.
I'm going to sign it for you.
I'm going to try to kiss it and touch it
and cuddle it.
Um,
I guess I would recommend,
you know,
one of my favorite thinkers in this
field is a guy named todd.
You're in Chang,
a brilliant professor,
uh,
in Cambridge,
and he wrote an amazing book called Bad
Samaritans.
And I'd definitely recommend that people
read that.
What's his name again?
His name is hodge.
Joon Chang.
Hogene Chang.
He's from South Korea.
See,
I find it hard to remember.
Non Christian sounding names.
What's the,
who is that African bloke?
Thomas.
Well,
Thomas Sankara,
Thomas Sankara.
We're looking him up and watch the South
Korean economists
fellow.
His name is,
uh,
is how Joon Chang.
Hi,
Joon Chang Thomas Sankara.
Next week there will be a quiz.
If you don't know anything about those
two people,
you will be banned from downloading this
podcast probably from itunes,
which is all part bloody problem.
But we will use these tools one day to
bring about a better world.
Jason,
thanks for coming on our show.
You've been absolutely alumut
brilliantly illuminating,
so clear,
so wonderful.
I feel smarter already.
I've memorized some of those things
you've said.
Well,
wonderful guest.
You are.
Thank you.
Thanks Russell.
Thanks.